coc mine d'or pour attribuer la
meilleure émission de l'aller les
nominés sont
dans la catégorie award de la meilleure
émission de l'année les nommés sont
mariés au premier regard l'émission les
candidats sont souvent sur la même
longueur d'onde tu prends côté gauche
tout côté droit je suis soulagé grand
dansant c'est cool je pense qu'avec
jennifer ça va très très bien se passer
mais je pense qu'on voit ses parts à
jénine juste pas prêtes à leurs vieilles
charrues
et si on se rencontrait l'émission où
certains auraient préféré ne jamais se
rencontrer
là
ça fait bizarre de voir un peu sa
cheville on est en direct et les lapsus
de laurent ruquier qui vont beaucoup me
manquer cette semaine c'est yannick
jadot qui sera rejoint rappelé par jan
hus ya du
lord et brew toujours à la pointe de
lecture est ce que vous connaissez jacky
michel
si on répond oui
et face à l'info qui a plus de budget
dès qu'ils montrent que tpm p
[Musique]
le cemi d'or de la meilleure édition de
l'année pour vous jean pascal
pascal praud gérer moi j'ai mûri pas
j'aime beaucoup parce qu'avant je trouve
très franc est-ce quelqu'un aujourd'hui
qui dit les choses un peu comme la vente
à scandale dans cette émission on peut
exprimer on peut dire les choses qu'on
pense et c'est assez rare et j'aime bien
ces missions pour moi ouais ça fait
partie d'une des meilleures ouais ouais
le divi une camomille peut-être non pas
laurent ruquier évidemment on est trop
mieux par hasard
messager couteau sous la gorge on est là
parce que j'ai bu beau et je l' ai déjà
dit ici laurent ruquier qui l'ont
inventé vraiment quelque chose ils ont
créé quelque chose avec cette émission
il recevait des personnes pour me voyez
jours seulement avant tout un pays dont
il est séparé alors oui il est parti en
fait lorsqu ils s'entendaient pas que la
production vous le savez très bien donc
il est parti de son plein gré on l'a pas
du tout poussé vers la sortie
on va retrouver laurent plus grand plus
fort et plus beau hugo boss merci très
bon moi je vais mettre à égalité on est
en direct et mario premier regard alors
ses deux deux salles bien fait devant
leurs deux ambiances pour moi on est en
direct ce qui me plaît beaucoup c'est
toute une ambiance qui a été créé un
plateau magnifique feinte pour moi c'est
un des plus beaux plateaux qui a été
fait
à la télévision que tu ne toutes et tous
les sujets sont balayés de la culture au
théâtre au cinéma à la chanson donc
c'est vraiment une émission hyper riches
à la politique aussi et mario premier
regard personnellement c'est la seule
émission qui me tire larmes j'aime
beaucoup ça
[Rires]
me regarde c'est que ça me manque de
diversité dans les candidats c'est à
dire que on n'a que des trentenaires qui
ont tous le même type moi j'aimerais
voir des personnes âgées voire en
physique un peu différent voilà c'est la
seule chose que je regrette sur cette
émission mais ça non ça me touche
beaucoup et motifs musicaux des clercs
christine kelly mois que j'adore que je
trouve éblouissante que je trouve
cultivé que je trouve intelligente
engagée également
bien sûr merci
sujet verbe complément
est un principe quand on s'exprime c'est
que les mots qui se suivent ça veut dire
quelque chose mais sinon c'est bien
cette c'est très bien
non je ne
[Musique]
suis pas méchant je vous rappelle près
de préserver mon émission intitulée et
on sait rien fait non minutes face à
l'audience
aujourd'hui non
non non bagués c'est vrai au premier
regard très bien pourquoi
pas trompé l'on dit réussi à lire
dis-moi pas parce que pour signer pour
ce que vous êtes
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais tant mieux pour
vous francesca gérer leur des pros déjà
pour pascal praud pour qui j'ai une
profonde amitié je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a mis le pied à l'étrier
déjà mais en plus c'est quelqu'un qui
vient du football qui rêvait qui rêvait
de faire de la politique et qui a réussi
à faire l'émission dont il rêvait et
qu'elle est quand même les cojones de
lancer non mais le but c'est une
émission dont rêvent les téléspectateurs
et on lui a fait confiance à et serge
nejjar lui a fait confiance et
maintenant ça cartonne c'est une
émission très digeste on peut regarder
on s'marre où il ya un petit peu des
couacs et franchement voilà c'est
agréable à regarder donc moi ça lors des
prochains jeux - mario premières au
premier tiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma décision est bonne à dire mais c'est
ce qu'il me faut une autre récession